a little boy in Iraq says he was sent to
live with an American family after he
was kidnapped by Isis the eight-year-old
appeared in an Isis propaganda video
after he was taken he spoke to Holly
Williams about this ordeal she is in to
hook in northern Iraq this morning Holly
good morning ah-hum Elias is an 8-year
old Iraqi boy who made it back from Isis
territory in November more than three
years after he was kidnapped by the
extremists but when he arrived in this
muddy refugee village his family
immediately noticed a change he'd
somehow learned to speak English
American family yeah and how long did
you live with them from
[Music]
yes you heard him right a ham spent two
years living with an American woman and
her four children in Raqqa he says then
the so called Isis capital in Syria what
was her name Sam Sam
amazingly this Isis propaganda video
released in August seems to confirm his
story
it shows a ham with a boy he identifies
as Yusuf the American family's oldest
child he says the family treated him
with kindness they were forced to make
the video by an Isis gunman he told us a
ham is a member of the Aziz religious
minority targeted by Isis when they
rampaged across Iraq in 2014 his leading
men were killed and women and children
were kidnapped the women later sold as
sex slaves a hum told us he was
separated from his mother who's still
missing and beaten before he was handed
over to the American woman named Sam her
husband and North African man was killed
by an airstrike he said
as the u.s. coalition pummeled Raqqa a
hum fled Isis territory with the
American family he told us before
becoming separated and now he misses
them where do you want to go me you want
to be with them it's an extraordinary
story but the woman he knew is Sam
remains a mystery we can't confirm that
she's a US citizen and we don't know how
she ended up in Isis territory or where
the family is now Gail a lot of
questions there thank you very much
Holly Williams reporting from northern
Iraq